make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with Shazam
I'm going to record this a little while
ago but I ended up getting sidetracked
but we are edging ever closer yes we are
in fact we are here now but I'm really
excited about this now here's a funny
thing the wizard Shazam the way he's
being depicted here is kind of
intriguing and it's one of the things
that I like about how Jeff Jones is
doing this when it came to the wizard
Shazam there was always something about
him that just sort of seemed a little
off it wasn't that he was a good guy but
he wasn't really a bad guy he was just
kind of in between and the way it goes
down here is someone intriguing insofar
as you end up having Billy Batson who
sort of hears this conversation going on
where you basically have this kind of
arguing taking place between the wizard
Shazam and his father right like that
you know there's kind of this great big
huge argument that goes on and then
Billy Batson father's taken out and
right off the bat the indication seems
to be that like the wizard Shazam is a
bad guy and it's kind of intriguing
because Geoff Johns sort of messes with
us and it's kind of like this guy seems
like kind of a good guy because Billy
Batson immediately starts to lose it
Billy's like why would you do this you
know ultimately the response of the
wizard is this power we're supposed to
be shared with your family but like you
are not ready to be a champion because
you don't really understand what it
means to be achieving kind of
back-stepping everything that he had
said but like when I chose you much like
I chose Black Adam I chose poorly and
it's just kind of like right off the bat
it's like he's just being a dick
you know and it's kinda like okay so
like why is he against Billy Batson all
of a sudden so of course Billy Batson
ends up lashing out against the wizard
and that wakes up the rest of the Shazam
family they end up going to the window
and finding Billy going head-to-head
against the wizard himself and it's one
of these crazy things right because what
he ends up doing is really just sort of
like separating Billy from his Shazam
powers right that kind of seems to be
the case or at least that looks to be
the cases like Billy seems to lose his
abilities you know even if only for for
a temporary amount of time but it's
interesting because he's like ultimately
I chose Billy Batson right where he
tries to take that power away
essentially the wizard is fighting
Shazam he's not fighting Billy and so he
can't really take the powers away he can
take them away from Billy in his human
form but he cannot take them away from
Shazam because Shazam is the power it's
like trying to take Shazam away from
himself it cannot be done and this is a
very important thing because what this
does while it can be easy to sweep under
the rug what this does is it establishes
this idea that when it comes to the
power of Billy when it comes to the
power of Shazam so long as Billy is in
his Shazam form his power cannot be
taken away
asked me back in his human form in order
to lose those abilities it's intriguing
it feels like a plot point that'll
become important later on down the line
now of course the rest of the Shazam
family jumps in and they all immediately
start going toe-to-toe with the wizard
Shazam himself and of course he manages
to overpower pretty much all of them and
that's where things get kind of
interesting because he's like in order
for me to succeed in my plan in order
for me to win I need all the power
restored to myself right I need all this
power brought back to myself you guys
won't be able to use it effectively you
don't know what you're doing and in a
lot of ways that's kind of a reasonable
point to argue because while the members
of the Shazam family are capable one of
the other things to bear in mind is they
are kids and kids are curious kids have
a tendency to leap before they look
right hence the reason why they ended up
in this whole story arc of like the
magic lands and the wild lands and all
that kind of stuff it was this obsession
with whether or not they could they
never stopped to think whether they
should and that's what that turned out
to be it's kids being kids and in
reality when it comes to this kind of
power when it comes to this kind of
scenario picking somebody to be a
protector really requires them to be
able to operate on a level higher than
something like a child now the reality
is this kind of flies in the face of
everything that we've seen with Shazam
now there's never really been an
instance where Billy Batson has
demonstrated ineptitude the inability to
carry out his powers or carry out his
role in a way to where he can be a
sufficient superhero for earth but at
the same time the way the Geoff Johns is
painting this we haven't really seen a
conflict like this before right when you
see Shazam using his powers and facing
off against villains sometimes it's a
villain of the week sometimes it's just
dr. sivana sometimes is alongside the
Justice League against some great big
huge threat darkside or like his
daughter Grail or something like that
but it's never never really seemingly
one of these things where it's like a
holy magical side of the conflict that
is explicit to Shazam and requires kind
of like a wholesale consolidation of
power we've never really seen that
before and it makes it intriguing right
it makes it interesting because what we
end up doing is jumping over to sivanna
himself and one of the things that mr.
mind basically tells him is look yes you
know for it for Humanity out there you
guys see the eyes as windows to the soul
but because the kind of power you
possess the reality is that your eye is
a doorway to anywhere and literally
taking the dagger of Shazam the infidel
dagger and stabbing himself in the eye
what it does is it basically erode the
locks it destroys the various securities
that are there that were put in place to
keep the various individuals house
within monster lands odd to keep them at
bay to keep them locked up essentially
they've all been free
and this is the concern that the wizard
Shazam was talking about because keep in
mind all these monsters that are here
are beings that are wildly powerful
right they were so dangerous across the
entirety of seemingly the multiverse
that they were locked away I used the
term multiverse fast and loose because
when it comes to the multiverse in DC
comics there really is only one rock of
eternity across the multiverse and there
may be different Shazam's in different
universes but there's only really one
rock of eternity we know that from Grant
Morrison's depiction of the multiverse
itself the result of this is that we're
not really gonna see like evil versions
of Shazam who are like Superman things
like that I think a lot of that's being
reserved for the Dark multiverse right
evil versions of Shazam evil Superman
evil Wonder Woman you know different
things like that like we saw evil
versions of Batman which are wildly
excited about but these various monsters
and beings are exceedingly capable and
this is the fear that the wizard of
Shazam hat that the monsters are gonna
be released and in order to basically
contain them and defeat them that is
going to take a lot of power now the
funny thing about this is the way is
depicted here by Geoff Johns it seems
like they're more powerful than the
seven deadly sins and if that's true
then we're talking about a huge amount
of power right because the seven deadly
sins are like a primordial evil they're
form and function is tied to the
existence of sentient beings right when
the first evil act was committed the
first instance of greed the first
entered an instance of like rage or
sloth or wrath or whatever you want to
call ever the case says that's when
those beings started coming into
existence right so as long as sentient
beings capable of emotions will exist so
well the seven deadly sins but these
guys seem to be on a different level of
power or a different kind of power
that's able to instill fear the only
person that's not freed here is
superboy-prime
and that's kind of the funny theme
because he basically tells these guys
like let me loose like free me get me
out of here and they all just kind of
ignore him and just sort of go forward
with their you know what it is they're
supposed to do essentially meeting up
going to battle with Shazam or whatever
the case is but Shazam continuing his
attack going against the wizard Shazam
suddenly everything basically stops and
the reason why is because Billy
basically makes the case that we've been
making this whole time he essentially
says when I first popped up yes you
didn't see me as worthy but you had to
look beyond the surface you had to look
deep inside what I was capable of and
what I could do to figure out that I was
worthy and ultimately you made the
choice to say I was worthy of having
this power what's changed if you're in a
position now to worry you're gonna fight
kids then what makes you believe you're
even worth
of this power and that's when the wizard
basically shifts and says I'm not sure
what you're talking about
I'm not trying to fight you you're not
my enemy here my enemy is your father
and he immediately goes on the attack
with Billy Batson's dad right and that's
kind of a crazy thing because then
suddenly like Billy basically slows him
down all right Billy is able to kind of
overcome the wizard and then ultimately
sends them away and that's where things
get kind of wild it's because initially
they're sort of like okay just like we
have a reprieve we can kind of rest now
and then suddenly Black Adam jumps into
the fray right and Black Adam basically
having been having been told by mr. mine
if you fight alongside me then I'll
ensure that your people of conduct are
going to be safe that no ill will come
of them because of the fact that Black
Adam cares only about his people in
conduct he basically goes to take out
Billy Batson's father and when that
happens ultimately you end up having
Billy batts his dad who basically kind
of runs off this spell and then manages
to overtake like Adam and when that
happens why Kadim is of course you know
kind of torn between the realms and sent
away and then in response to that Billy
Batson starts looking at his dad funny
because where everybody starts looking
at this and starts saying yeah you know
Billy Basson's dad to feed it Black Adam
and everybody's celebrating Billy's
question is how did you know that spell
and the response of his father is well
it's just you know it's real I have this
voice in my head right the wisdom of
Solomon you know it basically taught me
what this was and Billy's like but
that's not how that works the wisdom of
Solomon isn't a voice in your head that
tells you what to do in any given
situation
it's a feeling and that's sort of the
way that it's been for a long long time
how long it's been that way I'm not
entirely sure because I'm not the most
knowledgeable person when it comes to
Shazam but it's one of these things
where it felt kind of like it like an
intuition almost got like a spider sense
and that's when Billy kind of starts
putting two and two together in saying
if the wizard was after you you're
you're hearing a voice in your head
you're using spells you shouldn't know
how to use and you're saying you were
able to use these spells because there
was a voice in your head telling you how
to use them then you really are the
enemy you really are the bad guy you
wanted us all to fight you want a Black
Adam to be involved you wanted the
wizard to be involved you wanted all of
us to fight each other why why did you
want us distracted why did you want us
removed from everything going on and
that's when he starts to realize what's
going on he says this whole time we
thought mr. mind was inside of dr.
sivana that's not true he's not inside
dr. sivana
and that's when Billy bats his father
chimes in and says that is correct I've
been communicating with dr. sivana
but your father is the one that's my
host I've been in your father the entire
time and I saw this I was like holy crap
because
that's why Jeff John's stories are so
cool because like you think you know
what's going on right because if you
guys recall when it came to mist your
mind talking to you to dr. sivana
we never saw mist your mind in the mind
of dr. sivana we just saw mr. mind
inside somebody's head and talking to
sivanna and we just assumed that he was
there because of the fact of the way the
conversations were being done it's cool
to see the Jeff John still has it man
because then Billy Batson immediately
loses it right immediately starts going
off and then trying to take out his dad
but try not to destroy his dad and
that's what makes him the perfect host
right mr. mind knows but inside the mind
of his father there's really nothing
Billy can do right the only way to
basically take out mr. mind
it's so like uses energy on his father
and possibly destroy his father in the
process which is something that Billy's
not willing to do and so as a result of
that what is up happening is his portal
opens up and suddenly all of these
various forces from the monster lands
come pouring out right so now you have
all these enemies from the monster lands
who were here right the Red Queen of the
of the Oise endure land you've got
jeepers from the dark lands you've got
like all these evil beings who are here
that are getting ready to wreak havoc
all over the place but in the midst of
all that in the midst of all that while
all of that is happening we jump back to
the monster lands and the reason why is
because one of the characters named
dummy was basically promised freedom he
was promised freedom from mr. mind if
you were willing to help him but
somewhere along the line that seems to
have gone awry he's been left behind and
so while he's searching around trying to
locate everyone suddenly Here Come
superboy-prime I was left behind to I
was left behind to I was betrayed just
like you were but if you let me out if
you let me out of this if you destroy
that little red Sun over there that's
dampening my powers then we can
basically get revenge right we can go
and do our thing we can do whatever it
is that we have to do but we can fight
this fight and the dummy is taken in
he's like okay so he destroys this
little red Sun he basically eliminates
it when that happens
superboy-prime breaks out of his prison
destroys the dummy and then basically
says the first person I'm gonna take out
here is Shazam so my question is and
this is what I want to see I feel like
superboy-prime is gonna show up on the
scene and just immediately take out all
the monsters who were there and then
take out Shazam and the whole Shazam
family it's cool but officially ladies
and gentlemen superboy-prime
is free it's gonna be awesome this being
said guys we're gonna read this video to
an end if you are new here to come this
explained to make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the robb
cork you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and I will catch you all later peace I
want to say thank you to all of the new
patrons who have joined patreon.com
slash comics explain I want to give a
shout out to Henry young - Elias G David
J s Jacob H been John H Jason see Austin
s Austin H James O kristymatt in Jeff
are Joey M Steven Z sloth-like lu-david
see John H lean and mean that guy asked
questions all the time Adam Cajun gnosis
916 I want to say thank you to all of
you all this list is growing all the
time thank you joining the patreon
[Music]
you
[Music]
you